[Música]
la cualidad de superar la discordia
quisiera empezar compartiendo les la
idea de que es una cualidad una cualidad
al final del día es un rasgo es un
componente es la posibilidad que
caracteriza a una persona oa un grupo de
personas los chihuahuenses por
definición nos han enseñado a ser
valientes a ser nobles y a ser leales
se imaginan si una cualidad de los
chihuahuenses fuera el ser pacíficos
creo que sería interesante la idea creo
que sería importante tratar de ponerle
nuestra cabeza no sólo de los
chihuahuenses de los mexicanos creo que
tenemos la capacidad de ser educados en
formas en estrategias de poder resolver
nuestros problemas y nuestros conflictos
antes de entrar en la materia quiero
contarles una idea que les va a servir
para todo lo que van a escuchar el día
de hoy un cuentito chiquito pero real en
el año de 1736 el quien fuera presidente
de los eeuu posteriormente benjamin
franklin tuvo una idea en la ciudad de
filadelfia él sufrió un incendio en su
casa y no existía en ese momento un
departamento de bomberos él tuvo la idea
de unir un grupo ciudadano para crear un
departamento de bomberos o un
departamento de bomberos gratuito
público y que funcionara en toda la
ciudad de filadelfia la gente le dijo
que estaba loco que era una pésima idea
porque al final del día los ciudadanos
se iban a volver descuidados a la hora
de tratar los incendios los ciudadanos
no iban a poner atención en sus fuego en
sus fogatas en sus casas en la
electricidad en las lámparas y se iban a
crear un mayor número de incendios se
imaginan ustedes viven en una ciudad sin
un departamento de bomberos
si un departamento de bomberos gratuito
si un departamento de bomberos público
pues así como benjamín franklin tuvo esa
idea en 1736 así el día de hoy van a
escuchar un sinfín de ideas que pueden
sonar complicadas en su aplicación que
pueden sonar difíciles de entender que
pueden sonar en prácticas en el mundo en
el que vivimos el día de hoy pero yo
estoy convencido por lo menos que los
medios alternos de solución de
controversias son ese departamento de
bomberos el día de hoy que dentro de
cien años o dentro de cincuenta vamos a
voltear a este es decir válgame porque
nos tardamos tanto en profesionalizar y
en aplicar esta mediación esta
negociación en que todos supiéramos cómo
solucionar el conflicto
los punteros y yo nos llevamos bien
hemos hablado de negociación y mediación
como un tema nuevo cuando él platico mis
colegas abogados del arbitraje de la
mediación de la negociación me dicen es
que esas ideas que tienen el día de hoy
no deben o no van en la ideología y en
la idiosincrasia mexicana nosotros
estamos acostumbrados a pelearnos y
alguien nos tiene que decir quién está
bien y quién está mágico creo que desde
ahí estamos equivocados porque porque
los primeros tribunales y las primeras
cortes aparecieron en egipto en el año
3000 antes de cristo
y los otros cinco mil años la unidad la
humanidad y la existencia a la misma
había tenido la posibilidad de resolver
sus conflictos lo hacían de una u otra
manera
unos más pacíficos que otros
existen tres ejemplos que les quiero
comentar y les quiero platicar para
efecto de enseñarles que si sabíamos
resolver nuestros conflictos antes de
que un juez o una autoridad no estuviera
es que decir cómo se iban a resolver el
primero de ellos se llaman los
bosquimanos de kalahari o la gente sana
estas personas siguen existiendo el día
de hoy y viven en la región de kalahari
que se conforma entre botsuana y namibia
son personas nómadas y son tribus que
siguen existiendo desde originalmente
desde hace más de 5.000 años se
conservan y los gobiernos de botsuana y
namibia les ha dado su espacio para
seguir viviendo de la forma tradicional
en la que viven qué hacen ellos cuando
enfrentan un conflicto de acuerdo a las
reglas de la tribu si dos personas o más
tienen un problema es un problema para
toda la comunidad se sientan en una
fogata y nadie se puede levantar hasta
en tanto el conflicto no haya sido
resuelto
se imaginan sentarse en la mesa de su
casa
ustedes se pelean con su hermano con su
mamá o con su papá y que nadie tenga la
posibilidad de levantarse de comer de ir
al baño de tomar agua hasta que lo
resuelvan
creo que esa pura presión del resto de
los miembros de su familia ayudará a que
ustedes dialoguen y sientan la
posibilidad y la necesidad también de
resolver ese conflicto así mismo los
bosquimanos de kalahari lo hacen con un
grupo de las 100 207 300 personas que
conforman toda su tribu los conflictos
pueden llegar a hacer cosas desde un
tema simple sobre un plato hasta un tema
tan complicado como un asesinato y la
resolución de conflictos puede llegar a
durar hasta dos semanas sin que nadie se
levante de esa forma tú creo que
entonces allí hay una alternativa ha
venido existiendo desde hace más de
cinco mil años no es un tema nuevo no es
un invento en materia de mediación
el segundo ejemplo es monótono si el ban
ha escuchado últimamente no sabe
iglesias no se alimentó en club de
cuervos no es un tema nuevo no llegó por
una serie de netflix mexicana existe en
la isla de hawai desde hace más de 350
años que ese loco no pone es un ritual
de sanación personal y conflictiva e
incluso está reconocido por los
tribunales y las cortes de hawai cuando
una persona comete un crimen un crimen
menor se le da la posibilidad de acudir
con un sacerdote o con un líder de la
comunidad tradicional hawaiana a
practicar uno por uno por este tema
consta de cuatro pasos
el primero se llama perdón el segundo se
llama lo siento el tercero se llama te
amo y el cuarto se llama gracias
cómo le hago para resolver un conflicto
con esas cuatro palabras o piense en
cuándo fue la última vez que le
mencionaron un ser querido esas cuatro
palabras de la forma con de forma
consecutiva perdón no es lo mismo que lo
siento perdón involucra estar
arrepentido con el acto que se cometió y
buscar de la contraparte la posibilidad
de obtener
un perdón o una disculpa eso quiere
decir que reconoces que lo ofendí sta
sin embargo estás esperando que la
contraparte también acepte ese perdón
decir lo siento a diferencia ha pedido
perdón reconoce que está dispuesto a
cambiar a modificar la conducta y esa
diferencia perdón pedimos muchas veces
perdón por pegarle a alguien en la calle
perdón por pasarme un alto perdón por no
pagar una multa perdón por no pagar mis
impuestos a tiempo estás dispuesto a
decir lo siento a cambiar la conducta
hacerlo bien en tu casa en tu escuela
con tus amigos con tu novia con tu
esposa con tu esposo tercer punto
importantísimo te amo te amo es bien
fácil decirlo cuando estás en una cena
romántica cuando saliste de buenas
cuando te trataron bien en tu casa
y cuando estás en conflicto y es más o
menos fácil decirlo cuando le trata de
decir a un ser querido te amo mamá te
amo papá te amo esposa te amo novia
suena común
te amo delincuente te amo persona que no
me pagó una deuda que contra el que
contrajimos te amo bully de la escuela
que me robaste mi paleta
pues eso ese loco no pone y eso es lo
que se ha practicado en hawai por más de
cuatro siglos
por último gracias gracias por
escucharme
gracias por perdonarme gracias por ser
quien eres gracias por darme la
posibilidad de tener una relación
contigo vuelvo a lo mismo gracias es
fácil con alguien con quien tienes una
relación positiva no sé qué tan fácil
sea con alguien que verdaderamente te
haya lastimado pero esos son los cuatro
pasos de lo conozco no y son un creo yo
muy sencillos de recordar no tan fáciles
de practicar pero por ahí pudiéramos
empezar y por último la historia de la
bancarrota
en la época mercantil en europa los que
tenemos la posibilidad o hemos tenido la
posibilidad de estar en alguna ciudad
europea nos damos cuenta de que las
plazas centrales son cuadradas son
cerradas y en ese momento siglo 15 del
siglo 14 se utilizaban para comerciar
los comerciantes tenían una mesa en
frente de ellos en donde vendían cosas
vendían cosas las intercambiaban por
otras vendían animales comida alimentos
telas etc
esas cosas que vendían tenían un precio
y tenían un trato justo cuando algunos
de los comerciantes no pagaban su precio
o trataba de transar algún otro
comerciante de manera inequitativa el
líder de la plaza tenía la posibilidad
con un mazo de romper la mesa que estaba
enfrente de él de ahí viene el término
bancarrota el día de hoy lo utilizamos
como no ser solvente pero esa historia
viene desde los comerciantes europeos es
un poquito más directo si ustedes lo
quieren ver de alguna manera pero es un
tema de
medio alterno de solución de
controversias que se ha venido aplicando
físico directo si no cumples nosotros
mismos comunidad te vamos a juzgar sí
pero sin embargo te vamos a romper la
posibilidad de que siga lastimando al
resto de la comunidad todos distintos
algunos más pacíficos que otros pero han
venido existiendo por más de diez desde
cuatro o cinco o seis siglos
para que para que estamos tratando de
hacer esto en méxico porque queremos
buscar una forma de solucionar nuestros
conflictos que sea alternativa a los
poderes judiciales del estado de la
federación primero por el número de
litigios que tenemos en nuestro país en
el estado de chihuahua al año se
presentan estadísticamente 4100
expedientes abiertos a nivel federal y
se presentan más de 75 mil en todas las
materias civil penal mercantil familiar
laboral y de justicia administrativo
algo estamos haciendo mal entonces
estamos peleando demasiado existe un
estudio de derecho comparado en donde
dice que somos el lugar 72 para abajo en
el mundo en el tiempo de resolver los
conflictos en mexico como abogados hemos
venido trabajando poder legislativo en
cambiar a otros temas sin embargo en
promedio en méxico los conflictos se
resuelven en 4.2 años
4.2 años de pelearte creo que es un
desgaste físico emocional y económico
que no nos podemos permitir por eso creo
que está esta nueva forma o esta
replanteamiento de cómo solucionar los
conflictos es importantísimo y por
último
porque estamos eso es méxico y no crean
que los estados que están en verdes
también en méxico en los últimos 17 años
hemos registrado más de 68 mil
asesinatos
registrado y todos esos le pueden
imputar la causa que quieran el crimen
organizado el narcotráfico la violencia
es gente de fuera díganlo escuchen lo
lean leen la prensa pero todos esos
asesinatos salieron de un conflicto unos
más graves que otros violencia familiar
violencia de género inequidad injusticia
y si supiéramos escucharnos y si
supiéramos conversar y si buscáramos una
salida alternativa tal vez tendríamos un
méxico por lo menos todo en verde que
significa brevemente ese mapa los
estados que están en rojo
o guinda significa que tienen cinco o
más delitos registrados como graves por
cada 100 miembros de la población es
altísimo en la tasa los que están en
verde tienen uno eso no significa que
estén bien
ahora cómo le hacemos que creo yo y que
les quiero compartir como solución creo
que desde la educación primaria desde la
educación básica
a todos nos deberían enseñar a qué hacer
con un conflicto una vez que nace el
conflicto debemos de buscar la forma de
pararlo debemos intervenir debemos de
detenerlo y esa educación básica no se
nos enseña en la escuela en la escuela
hay un cuadro de honor
hay quienes saben más que nosotros hay
quienes siempre están por encima de los
demás
hay bullying
entonces cuántos de nosotros estamos
preparados preparados ya no se diga
dispuestos a intervenir a la mitad de un
conflicto a pararnos entre juana ni
pararnos entre pedro y decir saben que
déjense de pelear y escuchen se
conversen busquen cuál es el sentido
atrás de su problema y aquí hay otro
tema los conflictos pueden ser reales o
pueden ser aparentes muchas veces existe
una contraposición de ideas que es de
verdad que trasciende yo quiero una cosa
tú quieres otra mi interés es contrario
al tuyo y tenemos que buscar un punto
medio o un punto en el que las partes se
sientan satisfechas con como ceder
algunos de los temas esos conflictos se
pueden resolver con pláticas con tiempo
los conflictos más graves de acuerdo al
análisis psicológico y jurídico son los
que son aparentes cuando yo pienso que
tú tienes una idea contraria a la mía
cuando yo pienso que tú estás en
conflicto conmigo y no es así o cuando
los conflictos están desplazados
tenemos una idea de que este es nuestro
problema cuando realmente el problema
está del otro lado todo eso se puede
solucionar primero parando las
utilidades y segundo preparando o
terminando con los daños buscando la
forma de detener lo que ya se hizo mal
para compensar lo tercero llegando al
fondo del problema y que hacemos
escuchar todos con la mayoría de los
seres humanos tenemos la posibilidad de
oír pero no nos han entrenado a escuchar
escuchar implica amor implica empatía la
empatía es saber que el mensaje viene de
un transfondo diferente que lo que la
persona enfrente de ti te está tratando
de decir viene desde su experiencia y
que tú puedes entender una palabra o un
conjunto de palabras de una manera y la
persona que está en frente de ti las
puede estar tratando de decir de otra a
eso nos lleve escuchar diez veces que
dos personas no se pueden escuchar hay
veces que necesitan a alguien en medio
que esté decodificando ese mensaje que
ustedes que codificando
en cachitos ese problema y eso es lo que
me gustaría que sucediera en la
educación mexicana que nos enseñaran
tanto escuchar como recibir un mensaje y
escucharnos ante terceros y enseñarnos
hacer ese tercero que termine con el
conflicto ese es el mensaje principal y
ese es el proyecto que me gustaría
llevar a la educación básica a la
educación media porque esta clase o este
mensaje yo lo imparto en noveno semestre
de la carrera de derecho
creo que es un poco tarde y creo que es
un poco limitado el conocimiento y el
número de personas que lo reciben
creo que en méxico hemos venido
progresando para entender hacia dónde
vamos y cómo vamos a llegar hasta ahí
desde el 2008 a nivel constitucional se
incluyó la posibilidad tenemos 10 años
trabajando en cómo llegar a esta
solución de conflictos y aún no llegamos
verdaderamente creo que buscando la
forma de educarnos para resolver los
conflictos lograremos promover una
cultura de paso muchas gracias por su
tiempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]